This episode is brought to you by curiosity stream,
a subscription streaming service that offers over 2000 documentaries and
non-fiction titles unlimited access starting at just two 99 a month and 30 days
for free. If you sign up through the link below and use the code, biographics.
More on them in a bit.
On a chilly day in 1955,
an unremarkable scene unfolded in Alabama that would change American history,
a board, a segregated bus seamstress, Rosa parks was told to surrender her seat.
So a white man could sit down.
It was a moments that already played out thousands of times in Montgomery,
a Southern city languishing under racist Jim Crow laws.
But this time things didn't follow the scripts. Rosa parks refused to move.
It was a decision that changed everything removed from the bus and arrested
parks became a lightning rod for the racial tensions crackling through the South
led by Martin Luther King Jr.
Montgomery's black community boycotted the bus company for a staggering 381
days. It was African-American activism on a scale that the U S had never seen.
And it kick-started the civil rights movements.
And it was all down to one woman.
Born had done a Deere of U S race relations park grew up in a world where racism
was just a poisonous fact of life, but rather than keep her head low,
she fought back. Even before she boarded that bus. She was an activist,
a tireless pursuer of justice. Think you already know the real Rosa parks. Well,
we beg to differ.
When Rosa.
Alex was born Rosa Louise McCauley on February the fourth, 1913,
outside Tuskegee, Alabama.
It was into a time and place designed to make her feel worthless.
Ever since reconstruction, the South had existed under Jim Crow laws,
forcing whites and blacks to inhabit different worlds famously.
This meant African Americans eating at segregated lunch encounters,
drinking at segregated fountains and living in separate communities.
But the discrimination, it went deeper than that in the worlds of parks,
childhood. Why people well, Mr. Or Mrs. Collins or whatever,
while black people were James or Malcolm or Rosa as an
African-American,
you were expected to step off the sidewalk for a white pass and give up your
seat on the bus to never speak back.
Those who refused could find themselves fired from their jobs left permanently,
unable to find work. And that was just in the cities out in the countryside.
Things could get much worse when parks was two years old,
her parents business went under her father left and the mother was forced to
move in with her parents Rose and Sylvester redwoods and railroad pine level.
It was from her grandfather that young Rosa would get a first taste of activism.
Sylvester redwoods had a mixed race backgrounds,
outwardly appearing to be white. It,
his exterior masked a well of trauma as a child,
Edwards had been a slave on a plantation,
had been mistreated even by the lamentable standards of the time refused food
until he nearly starved to death. Now a free man.
He hated whites with a passion refusing to show any difference.
And often sitting out on the porch with a shotgun in his lap,
whenever white folk came nosing around,
it was a defined and admirable attitude.
It was also one that could have gotten him killed.
Jim Crow was also the era of lynchings to 4,400 people.
Three quarters of them African-American were murdered by their white neighbors
for the smallest perceived infractions at their height.
These lynchings took place out in the open attracting huge crowds of smiling
whites who held their children up to get a good look at the mutilation body.
It was murder as a party.
It was a carnival one with a very clear message for black people.
That message you could be next. The same year.
Park's moved in with Sylvester and Rose Edwards.
The KU Klux Klan was reborn in Georgia after four decades lying dormant by
1916, it had spread to Alabama. By the time parks was 10,
it would boast 150,000 members in our home state alone for parks them into
Charles had lived beneath a shadow of violence. As a girl,
she would lie awake at nights. Listening as the KKK, when writing,
she heard the lynchings.
Once she even witnessed the Klan parade ride pasta doorway,
a show of strength of white impunity on that occasion,
Sylvester Edward stood on the porch, shotgun loaded, calm Lisa in the crowd.
Just daring them to try something yet. Despite this backdrop of fear parks,
didn't let herself be intimidated.
There's a great story from when she was a girl of a white boy who shoved her off
the sidewalk, parks calmly stood up,
dusted herself off and then shoved the white boy on his.
[inaudible] then burst into tears.
His mum shriek did Rosa demanding to know why she did that.
Park's comedy replied.
I didn't want to be pushed seeing how I was not bothering him at all.
It's kind of great that even from this early age,
we can see the fire burning and Rosa parks refusal to be a second class citizen,
but make no mistake. It was a hard life on our way to school.
White kids would throw rocks at her during the summers.
She was forced to work all day long,
picking cotton to help a family make ends meet in short Rosa parks.
His only life was just that of another poor black girl suffering under Jim Crow.
But this time the system was going to meet its match rather than let herself be
ground down.
POCs would wind up being the one who helped tear the whole rotten edifice down.
[Inaudible].
Although she was intelligent,
bad luck conspired to leave at Rosa parks with little in the way of a formal
education, aged 11. She joins Ms. White's industrial school in Montgomery,
which had mostly white teachers and mostly black students.
But even this amount of mixing was too much for the city,
which closed the school down.
Although parks would start again as a new school should soon be forced to drop
out, to care for a dying grandmother and ill mother.
As a result of their new job,
battle parks was able to get this as a seamstress and a chef factory,
still something must've gone, right? Because a year later in 1932,
she was introduced to Raymond Parks, Ababa by train.
Raymond was lacking in formal education, but that didn't mean he was stupid,
always well-dressed and always read up on every subject that matters Raymond's
was sharp as a pin, and he knew it in his spare time.
He organized defense meetings to try and help the Scottsboro boys,
nine African-American teenagers.
Who'd been falsely accused of raping white women.
It was dangerous work and most meetings took place around a table,
heavy with loaded guns, but it was also the coolest thing.
19 year old parks that ever heard Raymond's completely swept her off her feet.
He proposed to her on their second date and before the year it ended,
the two were married.
But if parks had dreamed of getting involved in Raymond's activism,
her dreams would soon be crushed. Raymond's thought it too dangerous.
The whole loss of them might get lynched at any time.
So parks was forbidden from attending the Scottsboro meetings instead of sitting
quietly on the porch,
as the men talked inside still Raymond's was a supportive husband,
encouraging her to, and our high school degree, something she did in 1933.
After that,
it was a series of menial jobs that my significance of which took place on an
army base as it became ever more apparent. There's another war was looming.
The FDR administration issued an order desegregating army bases.
When parks began working as a secretary at Maxwell field,
just outside of Montgomery,
she was shocked at life in a fully integrated environment.
She could sit next to whoever she wanted on the bus eats in a mixed canteen,
have white women serve our coffee.
She later claims you might say Maxwell base opens my eyes to how it could be
yet. The moment she steps off the base every evening,
it was back back to riding in the Negro section of the bus back to being a
second class citizen back to a world where black and always looking over your
shoulder as the decades ticked past and parks turns 30.
Raymond's began to Thor on the idea of his wife doing activist work in 1943,
they both joined the NACP working long hours as volunteers for
parks.
This was a crazy time and AACP charged her with recording racist violence across
Alabama. This meant going out and collecting graphic accounts of beatings,
whippings, and rapes that were doled out by whites.
The most horrific case was the RACI Taylor case in September, 1944,
a married black woman was abducted by a gang of white men who blindfolded her
and took turns sexually assaulting her in the aftermath.
Parks was sent to take a story only to be menaced by the local sheriff the
entire time she was in town.
Although parks succeeded in making racy Taylor national news,
she couldn't change the world.
She lived in an all white jury dismissed the case in five minutes.
Although the names of Taylor's abusers were unknown.
They never faced justice come 1947.
Rosa parks was famous across Alabama as a fiery activist.
She even gave a speech that year, the local NACP convention,
for which she received a standing ovation,
but it wouldn't be her civil rights work that would make parks famous.
It would be a single bus ride.
[Inaudible].
History of the civil rights movement.
Perhaps no other figure comes as such a petty Dick as James F
like a Montgomery bus driver,
Blake was charged with enforcing segregation on his vehicle.
Also he'd have you believe in reality driving because we're given discretion.
I've uh, how seriously they took the rules.
So while you've got some jobs worth who always made black people surrender their
seats to whites, you also got some who just turned a blind eye,
but not James Blake to those who've written. His boss.
Blake was notorious for being a weapons grade.
He forced black people to come through the front door pay and then made them get
back off again and get back home and buy the red,
or not only that he sometimes drove off as they were making their way to the
back of the bus, leaving them penniless and without a ride in the freezing cold.
So congratulations, James Blake,
you are being discussed on a channel that has made videos on Stalin,
and you're still somehow the pettiest Tyron's that we've ever encountered.
Rosa parks.
Should we had a run in with Blake during her early days as an NACP investigator?
Yeah, 1943. She bought it as bus through the front door,
paid for a ticket and then refuse to get back off and go to the rear door.
The incident ended with Blake grabbing her arm and shouting at her until parks
ran from the bus. Given what we know of Rosa parks today,
it seems odd that she was involved in a separate bus incident 12 years earlier,
but that's only because we're looking at it with hindsight in 1943 or even
1952,
there was no evidence that the spark for civil rights might come from segregated
buses, 1943 parks. It wasn't all like great.
I'm going to do this again in a decade and watch the world change.
It was only in 1953,
the activists started to see the potential for buses to become a powder keg
that's because 1953 was the year Baton Rouge showed what could be done
that June a Southern reversal in busty segregation in the Louisiana Capitol
exploded into direct action.
Black churches organized the neat de boycott of the bus system costing the
company thousands of dollars.
Although the gains made by the end of the book to a few,
they made activists is prick up across the South.
If it could be done in Baton Rouge, why not?
And say Montgomery by now it was clear.
Something was building below the surface of Southern society of volcano.
There was a bound to erupt in 1954,
the Supreme court ruled in Brown and board of education.
That schools must be desegregated while this was a victory.
It was one that was met with immediate backlash just a year later,
14 old Emmett till was lynched in Mississippi for answering back to a white
woman.
Clearly whites were still ready to use violence to keep hold of that privilege.
By now, the Alabama and AACP was already committed to finding a test case,
the bus desegregation.
They nearly succeeded in November when teenage Claudette Colvin refused to give
up her seat to a white person and was arrested and roughed up.
But NACP discovered she was both pregnant and unmarried and decided not to
pursue the case,
knowing the broadsides that would be launched against whoever had it into the
test case.
They simply couldn't risk using someone without a spotless reputation.
Another near miss was Jo Ann Robinson and educator from home Marie not long
after the Claudette Colvin Robinson got on the bus and deliberately sat in a
whites only seat.
It seems that she was trying to spark a confrontation in order to get arrested.
But when the driver started screaming and swearing at her,
her nose broke and she left the bus. And so December, 1955,
arrived with the activist community, still waiting for the spark,
still waiting for the test case that would give them their shot to blow Jim Crow
wide open. Fortunately, Rosa parks was about to become that very spark. Now,
just before we continue with today's video,
I want to take a quick moment to thank today's sponsor. Curiosity stream.
Curiosity stream is a subscription streaming service that offers over 2000
documentaries and non-fiction titles from some of the world's best filmmakers,
including exclusive originals. Now, if you're enjoying this video,
then why not try out curiosity stream for free and check out their great
docu-series 101 events that shaped the 20th century.
If you're enjoying this event, which certainly shapes the 20th century,
that it's going to be a great series to check out.
Curiosity stream is available on many platforms, Roku, Android.
There's a web app. X-Box one smart TVs, iOS Chromecast. The list just goes on.
If you've got some sort of screen,
you're probably going to be able to watch curiosity stream on it.
Get unlimited access starting at just two 99 a month. And for you guys,
the first 30 days are completely free.
If you sign up at the link below and use the promo code biographics during the
signup process, it's a great way to support the show and let's get back to it.
[Inaudible].
1955 Was a chilly day in Montgomery. It was also a busy day.
At least if your name was Rosa parks by now,
parks was working in a department store,
fixing dresses with Christmas approaching.
It was already a busy time and parks had a NACP work on top of that.
She spends her entire coffee break making NACB calls into lunch hour meeting
with a lawyer to discuss a case. By the time she left the building at 5:00 PM,
she was as taught as a dog. The line is a regular bus stop was crazy.
So she ran some errands. By the time she came back,
the queue had thinned out a little Abbas, pulled up POCs,
got on and took a seat beside an African-American man in the middle section,
known as no man's land. These were the un-designated seats,
the ones theoretically reserved for neither whites nor blacks in practice
though,
the drivers would often eject blank people from these rows when whites were
forced to stand, this was especially the case.
If the driver happened to be a bit of an Epic Dick,
and can you catch guests who the Epic Dick driving Rose's boss that day was
as the bus moved on and it got busy up two more blank.
People came to sit in the same row as parks.
Eventually the bus was so full that a white man was forced to stamps it's.
At this point that James Blake did what James Blake did best.
The driver came to the road.
Parks was sat on and told all four black people to move. When everyone refused,
he threatened to call the cops one by one,
the other three really stood up and went to the back. But not Rosa.
Instead of leaving,
she slid across to the window showing she had no intention of moving to this
day. It's onset. And what was going through our head,
the Reverend Jesse Jackson ones claims that she was thinking of Paul lynched,
Emmett till Rosa said, she thought about going to the back of the bus,
but then she thought about Emmett till, and she couldn't do it.
The popular story is that she was just tired from work,
from being treated like garbage.
And other view is the parks was all too aware that the NACB needed its test case
and had decided that it would be her Blake auditor to get up. But parks refused.
He threatened to call the police to which she calmly replied. You may do that.
So Blake did, what's interesting is that the policeman, which is,
does unhappy with Blake's Bulletproofers everybody else.
They tried to diffuse the situation,
but when neither Blake nor parks would budge,
they reluctantly led Rosa parks away. Parks later said they asked her,
why didn't you just stand up? I don't know. She replied.
Why do you push us around? I don't know the laws, the law, after that,
it was a trip to the local jail that parks use telephone goal to notify Raymond
who freaked out terrified should be assaulted in a cell, but no, all the,
and was the parks was fingerprinted and then spent the nights behind bars
actually slept though the wheels were already turning through Raymond's NACP and
other groups found out about the arrest across the nights.
And 35,000 flyers were distributed across Montgomery's black communities calling
for a bus boycott. Children brought the flyers home from school.
Black churches urged their congregations to boycott the buses that Monday.
One of the preachers doing that urging was a 26 year old called Martin Luther
King, Jr. Newman town, and virtually unknown. Even in Alabama,
Dr. King had no intentions of becoming a household name yet.
The stage was now set for his own dizzying rise to prominence by Sunday evening,
the citizens of Montgomery were ready as he went to bed that night. And okay,
confided that had considered the boy boycott a success.
If only 60% of black writers participated this all,
could he have known that the real figure would exceed his wildest dreams?
On Monday.
December the fifth, 1955, Rosa parks went on trial.
The proceedings were fairly undramatic box was fined $10 and ordered to pay $4
in court costs a pretty small sum. Even at 1955,
the real action was happening outside that morning.
Dr. King has a way you can do a jaw dropping site.
Nearly all the buses in Montgomery's black areas were empty far from stopping at
60% of ride. As the boycott had pulled in nearly a hundred percent.
And so began the most legendary boycott in us history for
381 days.
Montgomery's black citizens avoided the buses using creative means to get to and
from work. At first cabs judged African-American ride is only 10 cents,
but the city passed. Despiteful more forcing them to charge a minimum of 45.
So the black community organized a community taxi system,
which made scheduled rides around town acting sort of like a backup bus.
But while the boycott effected the whole of Montgomery, it affected Rosa parks.
Most of all, usually when the story of parks is told,
it stops with a refusing to get off the bus and then skip straight to that
famous photo of her riding an integrated bus after the boycotts.
There's a good reason for that Rose's life. During the boycott, it was, I work,
none of our black colleagues would talk to her less.
They got reputations as troublemakers.
She was fired for her activism in January, 1956. At the same time,
Raymond's work brought in a new rule, forbidding people to discuss Rosa parks.
So he quit in disgust, penniless and unable to find new work.
The two were then left, traumatized by slander and death threats. First,
the slander barely had the boycott started.
Then fake news started crawling out of the woodwork.
Segregationists said anything they could about POCs that she was a communist,
that she was factually Mexican,
that she had a car and didn't even need to ride a bus. It was the same old crap.
You still see today to the messenger. So you don't have to hear the message.
But in 1955,
some people went further parks and Raymond started receiving death threats,
a steady stream that caused Raymond to have a minor breakdown.
Then on January the 30th,
the segregationist bombed Martin Luther King's home while his children were
inside. Luckily no one was hurt.
And MLK used that act of violence to advance his message of peaceful protest
telling supporters. I want you to love our enemies. Be good to them,
love them and let them know that you loved them, but parks wasn't some Saint,
she was just a regular woman and the violence terrified her nor was that test
case. Even going ahead,
although parks was the face of the Montgomery bus boycotts,
her case was actually dropped by organizers.
When they realized that they had three better ones,
that they could use all that violence,
all those threats and parks wasn't even part of the lawsuit anymore. Finally,
in November of 1956,
the case made its way before the Supreme court in a major decision,
the justices ruled against segregating buses.
Although the city of Montgomery trying to appeal,
it was refused on December the 20th. Montgomery was issued with a formal paper,
ordering an end to segregation on public transport. The very next day,
the boycott lifted Martin Luther King and Rosa parks, both separately roads.
The new integrated bus system that day parks was even photograph looking
wistfully out the window.
A Wiseman sat behind her to show that the old system was now gone and they'd
done it against all the odds.
One lone protest by Rosa parks had shaken up the whole of Montgomery.
It had shown black people what they could achieve with community action.
It was everything everyone had dreamed of. It was a happy ending.
Wasn't it?
[Inaudible].
Normally the story of Rosa parks ends out here with Montgomery's bus services
integrated in the civil rights movement, gaining steam,
but sadly life isn't a pre-packaged lifetime movie where the credits roll and
everyone goes skipping off into the sun life.
After the bus boycott was hard for parks and Raymond's unbelievably.
So thanks to Rose's notoriety,
neither of them were able to find work in Alabama.
Even civil rights organizations would entitle them most were run by men who took
one, look at parks and said,
this isn't work for women by 1957 parks couldn't even afford medicine to treat
her stomach ulcers.
She tried moving to Virginia to work at the Hampton Institute,
but they wouldn't give her a lodging. So quits on top of economic worries,
the threats of violence hadn't receded with the boycotts end,
there was a real urgent danger to parks his life so long as she remained in the
South in 1957,
a family convinced her to relocate to Michigan for our own safety. Well,
while that took care of the danger, it didn't take care of the economic side.
One little bit by 1960 jet magazine was describing POCs as a tatted
rag of a form of self penniless.
Detriot an alien with stomach ulcers and a throat tumor compressed into two
rooms with our husband and mother. It was a painfully low point in parks,
his life and undeserved ends. Luckily,
this was also the moment that things began to turn around the lag because he
profile seemed to stir some consciouses. NACB paid off parks, his medical bills,
allowing her to get a cancer operated on shortly after Raymond finally managed
to find work. And soon the couple were back home sound,
financial footing that meant they lived to see Lyndon B Johnson signed the civil
rights act into law. In the summer of 1964,
it meant parks was able to join the campaign to get John corners elected to
Congress in Paris, by convincing Martin Luther King to endorse the candidate.
Something King rarely did as a reward.
Connie gave her a salary position in his office. One,
she kept right up until her retirement. Interestingly, by this point,
pox was taught of King's philosophy of nonviolence. Malcolm X was saying,
if we can protect ourselves again, violence,
it's not actually violence in our POS. That's just self protection,
trying to keep from being victimized with violence, sadly parks,
wouldn't have to see both of these icons assassinated Malcolm X in 1965 and MLK
in 1968, 10 years later in 1977,
Raymond died of cancer and suddenly parks was all alone.
So how does this was the park?
I also lived long enough to see yourself transformed into an icon right into the
late 1970s. She was still receiving death threats from segregationists,
but at some point the tide began to turn and things began to change. In 1996,
she was awarded the essential medal of freedom by a white president.
Who'd grown up in the segregated South three years later in 1999,
she was also awarded the congressional gold medal.
By the time parks died on October the 24th, 2005, she was globally famous.
A story was told in textbooks. Kids heard about her in school. After a death,
a body was placed on the road Tundra and Capitol Hills so people could pay their
respects only the second African-American to ever be afforded that honor.
Eight years later, in 2013, a statue of how it was added to the rotunda,
the third statue of black person to ever be placed in the building today.
Rosa parks is no longer a met person. She's an icon.
One who encapsulates an entire era and entice struggle.
Children learn about her. Her name is everywhere on buildings and streets.
And yes,
the real parks is sometimes almost forgotten in telling her tale over and over.
Parks has been reduced in the public consciousness to just a symbol,
easily understandable as the tale of the Tod woman who refused to give up her
seat may be it's important to remember that the sanitized version leaves out
all of the human parts,
that it leaves out the violence parks grew up with the financial misery that she
suffered for holding her grounds,
all the things that would have broken a lesser person it's uncomfortable to hear
because we all like a fairy tale.
We'd all like to believe parks was recognized as a hero from day one,
rather than hearing that taking a stands nearly destroyed her. And yet,
in a way, this bleak aversion just makes that much more inspiring.
Here was someone who wasn't a Saint,
wasn't a tired working woman with sore feet, but an activist,
someone who saw the degradation suffered by the black community and decided she
had to speak out no matter what the consequences by recognizing this darker side
of her story,
hopefully we too can be inspired to do the right thing because as the tale of
Rosa parks proves, one person really can change the world.
And so I really hope you enjoyed this video. If you did,
please do hit that like button below.
Don't forget to subscribe and I'll see you next time.